So the end of this lesson,
I just want to quickly summarize what we have covered.
I've talked about what is a digital image and
how can you make it into a computational object.
We've talked about different types of formats of images, black and white, color.
And I've talked about histograms and
other ways of extracting simple statistics of an image.
And again, we have not talked about what they would be good for, but
that's coming up soon.
So, in the next lesson we will actually get into is now, once we
know what we know about images, how can we do simple processing and filtering.
And actually that's where some of the interesting things that I want you to
play around with actually becoming really important.
So far in all of the lessons we've looked at right now we're just looking at
the pixel itself.
We'll also be looking at what happens in the neighborhood of the pixels and
how do you actually do combinations of information one pixel to the other.